the Microsoft band has been out for a
while in the US but as is Microsoft's
prerogative they did the same thing with
the surface pro 1 it is only just landed
in the UK as is my prerogative I decided
I had to get my hands or wrists on one
on day one so I've now been playing with
it for a couple of days what do I make
of it this is Microsoft's attempted to
fit fit style health tracker merge with
an Apple watch style SmartWatch its
closest competitor then is probably
something like Samsung Galaxy gear fit
but it's way cooler than that rather
than straddling the line equally between
SmartWatch and fitness tracker the band
is definitely leaning more towards the
dedicated trackage side of things and
it's absolutely packed with sensors more
so than pretty much any other device in
fact specifically it comes with a
microphone a UV sensor a continuous
heart rate monitor galvanic skin
response sensor which measures skin
conductivity that's telling the band
when you're wearing it gyro meter
accelerometer GPS ambient light sensor
and skin temperature sensor all of this
collects data for you to enjoy via the
built-in display or through a connected
app on your Windows Phone iPhone or
Android device in short it provides a
very detailed tracking session during
workouts runs sleep and daily activity
in terms of productivity you get the
ability to see notifications calendar
entries and incoming calls and you can
also respond with preset text messages
Windows Phone users will also have
access to Cortana and the ability to
record voice memos and even respond to
texts with an on-screen keyboard you can
also install apps on the device seeing
as Redmond have released the sdk to
developers I have pimp my band which is
how I got this cool deus ex wallpaper on
my meat aisle which is what they call
the home page right now there's
definitely more available for the
windows phone user though there's even a
pong game I'm going to be developing for
this myself
soon though and I'll share any apps i
create with you all when I first got my
device I was disappointed to find it
felt uncomfortable to wear turns out
though I had the wrong size and had to
get one smaller and then it was much
better so if you are buying one of these
make sure you try them on first or at
least carefully examine the guide the
Microsoft supplies once you do get the
right size it should fit quite tightly
but there's a neat classf adjusting it
as you need to it can be worn on either
wrist as well facing either inwards or
outwards this is pretty handy as it
means you can change the way you're
wearing it depending on what you're
doing I prefer wearing it on my right
arm during workouts for instance am I
left when I'm sleeping that's because my
brain is more used to having something
on my left and I find it a lot less
disturbing as a result overall it's
relatively comfortable there is fairly
large if you're typing you'll have to
hover your hands over the keys though
technically you should be doing that
anyways I wore it when I wrote this
review so obviously it's serviceable
having the screen on the inside is
actually a cool way to wear it though as
it means you can check the notifications
and the time without looking rude
overall it's just about comfy enough to
wear all day and it doesn't really get
in the way during workouts I work while
working out with a punchbag earlier and
even that didn't get interfered with the
screen looks nice even if for the rest
of the band is a bit uninspiring I
actually like that it isn't trying to be
a fashion accessory it's understated
than that I can wear it like a bracelet
and still have my nice watch from my
fiance on my other wrist without looking
odd like I'm wearing two watches this
was actually one of the big reasons I
chose this one over something like the
Fitbit surge getting notifications is
sort of useful it means I'm less likely
to missing the point important text
which is handy and it does prevent me
from getting for my phone at my pocket
so often I like having my calendar on
here to the alarm / timer is also kind
of handy as is checking the weather
other than that though I think it's
definitely mostly Windows Phone users
who will get the most out of this as a
Productivity device that said Cortana is
rumored to be coming to iOS and Android
seen so maybe we'll get in on the action
oh and you can also pay for coffee at
Starbucks with it so there's that
what this is really about though is
fitness tracking and that's what the
Microsoft band does really really well
in the past I've been using the jawbone
up as well as s health on my note for
the band is way superior to those thanks
to the built-in GPS constant heart rate
monitoring and excellent app of course
the Microsoft band acts as a pedometer
and count your steps as you'd expect in
these devices but what it also does is
to measure your heartbeat regularly
meaning that you can see how many steps
you've taken and how that has affected
your heart rate at each point if you're
going to run you switch on the run mode
and it record your heart rate even more
frequently as well as mapping your route
on the inbuilt GPS and even measuring
elevation this is all then synced
immediately with the Microsoft health
app on your mobile device of choice and
it lets you check everything when you
get home you can see your pace at
various points in the run you can see
your heart rate mapped against your
speed and elevation and you can thereby
set goals and see what's getting you the
most worn out the health app is great
but what's actually even better is the
dashboard where you can view all this
information in more detail for your
browser when you do a workout meanwhile
you can select that mode and it will
measure your heart rate and calories
burned during the training this is great
for something like high intensity
interval training and is motivating
while you're doing a session you can
also see how long you've been working
out which I also find quite handy also
interesting is the unique option to go
through branded workouts you construct
you on which exercises to do and then
use the durometer and accelerometer to
count your reps and guide you through
the session big names like Gold's Gym
have workouts on there so if you're
looking for ideas this is a pretty cool
one during sleep you get your movement
and heart rate monitors which together
gives them that information to ascertain
whether you're in light or restful sleep
you can see how often you woke up and
you can see what your resting heart rate
is one downside is conspicuously absent
swim mode however which is due to the
fact that the band is water resistant
but not waterproof this is alarming as
it means I'll need to buy another
expensive gadget when the inevitable
band 2 comes out the accuracy of the
heart rate monitor is also something
that's a little questionable with
varying reports abound generally it
seems the consensus is that the sensor
is good for a wrist-worn device but not
as accurate as a chest strap which is
what you'd expect your luck with it
might also depend on things
your skin pigment and the visibility of
your veins I personally have no problem
as I'm pasty in my veins are fairly
bulging the numbers corresponding with
what I would expect and what I know
about myself as long as the device is
consistent I see that as being the most
important point overall though it's all
very cool and the plethora of sensors
need to get a lot more information than
you would from another device what I'm
most excited about though is the future
updates that are no doubt in store
already Microsoft has been listening to
users and adding new features like a
bike mode and they keep talking about
how they're going to be making better
use of all the information in future for
instance right now you can use the UV
sensor to see whether you need to wear
sun cream but in the future you could
also potentially say see how the amount
of Sun outside is affecting your heart
rate during runs the galvanic skin
response sensor is currently being used
to measure whether or not you're wearing
your band but apparently you can also
send stress by sensing changes in the
conductivity of your skin and as more
developers come on board there's
generally a ton of potential here which
I'm excited to see fulfilled overall the
band is a neat little SmartWatch but
it's a great health tracker it could be
a bit smaller and it would be nice to
take it swimming but other than that
it's pretty much top of its class the
question is whether or not you really
need the health tracker at all to that I
would say certainly not but they're
definitely fun and useful for motivating
yourself and for learning more about
your own body any body builder knows the
importance of instinctive training
knowing how the next workout is going to
affect their body and stimulate growth
or not for those who haven't developed
this intimate knowledge of their own
body yet biofeedback via some form of
health tracker is definitely a very
useful way to develop this and to test
the effectiveness of new workouts for
fitness enthusiasts meanwhile seeing
stats and measuring progress as a highly
rewarding process even if you can get a
little anal about it also I love it
because I like feeling like a superhero
the dial on my wrist so that was my full
Microsoft band review hope you enjoyed
it I tried to do something a bit more
professional there I wrote a script and
I did editing and all sorts so yeah if
you found it useful please like and
subscribe i'll be uploading more like
this in future if you want to see the
written review check out the website the
pioneer calm and yeah thanks for
watching and i'll see you on the next
one bye for now